[Musique]
tous les ans
la le ministère de la Culture prévoit
les nuits de la lecture en bibliothèque
al il y a pas que les bibliothèques les
librairies il y a a certains musées les
archives et c'est c'est un moment dédié
à la lecture surtout à la lecture
publique la nuit de la lecture c'est un
moment aussi où on va combler les les
envies de certains lecteurs qui sont
très friants de de ce genre de
d'animation vraiment dans la localité de
proximité ce qui est pour nous très
important parce qu''on a une
bibliothèque de
proximité alors le vendredi on va faire
une vraie nuit parce qu'on va fermer à
22h on va proposer une soirée jeux de
société parce que nous avons une
ludothèque à la bibliothèque et donc on
va présenter des petits jeux familiaux
des petits jeux aussi d'ambiance des
nouveautés et le samedi ce sera plus une
journée familiale aux horaires de
d'habitude 10h 18h où là on va proposer
alors des rendez-vous compte le matin 3
6 ans à peu près et un atelier de
d'écriture autour du cheval parce que on
a décidé de travailler
[Musique]
l'équitation